the day started out actually at an MSNBC
live taping that's taking place a couple
blocks away from the Trump rally and I
kind of went there first cuz I was very
nervous about going to the Trump rally
and I went there first because it was
more of a comfort zone and just started
chatting with people and everyone I told
I was like I'm thinking about going over
the rally and they were like don't do it
they're horrible people they're the
lowest of the low
they're going to harass you one woman
actually offered me her pepper spray to
take with me and I was like no I think
I'm gonna be fine it'll be okay
[Music]
can you just go through a little bit of
what your political leanings were
beforehand yeah I've called myself a
liberal for like 20 years I've been a
Democrat since I was 18 years old since
I was able to register to vote and
frankly I never really saw myself
leaving the Democratic Party up until
all this started happening so then this
all happens and you did the scariest
most evil thing someone can do you went
to a Donald J Trump rally I did but we
have to back up a little bit cuz it it
didn't actually start there it started
okay so it started several months before
the Trump rally and I when all this was
going on I basically said you know I
need to get out of my echo chamber I
need to get out of my liberal echo
chamber because I that was the only
people I was hearing from not just
liberals but progressives and all this
and I made this concerted effort to
start listening to voices that I thought
I would disagree with and my husband who
has always been a little bit more
conservative than me said Carlin you
should listen to ben shapiro you should
watch ben shapiro you'd like him and I
said no Victor I'm not watching ben
shapiro ben shapiro is sitting and then
i mean my husband's a pretty smart guy
so eventually I listened to him I waited
until he was out of the house cuz I
didn't want to give him that point but
eventually I listened and you know turns
out as you know Ben Shapiro is not
saying he's just like a conservative guy
who is also really funny and really
smart and I just happened to disagree
with him on something and from there it
was kind of down the down the YouTube
rabbit hole where I just started
listening to all these different people
and discovering
this conservatives are really not what I
thought they were it wasn't the
perception that I had and you know
living in New Hampshire I'm very lucky I
get to see all the political candidates
up close and at one point or another I
had seen every other political candidate
and I thought you know Donald Trump's
coming to town well why not this is like
my big graduation exercise yeah so all
right so you go well first off tell me a
little bit more about the those sort of
what I described as factory-settings'
that you were a liberal for 20 years did
it did it have any real meaning to you
or it was just sort of like where I
think a lot of sort of somewhat
apolitical people are where it's sort of
like Oh Democrats good Republicans bad
Democrats care about poor people
Republicans care about money like you
know for the person that's not purely
political it's just sort of the stuff
that you kind of get culturally is that
basically where you were yeah I mean
kind of I I think I was very active
politically when I was younger and then
growing up I kinda and really after
Obama was elected I kind of shut it all
off I was like okay he's got it at
Democrats in office it'll be fine but
really what I didn't realize is how much
Democrats have changed since you know
between W and what we have now and that
was really the big shocker for me
because I became a Democrat because I
didn't like I didn't like people telling
me what to do I didn't like people
telling me what music I could listen to
or trying to slate their religion or
what I could wear or all these things
and that was what and who to love as
well and that was why I joined
originally and it didn't occur to me
that the Democratic Party had changed so
much from the thing I joined oh I have
heard this story before what what did
you think intuitively about the
Republicans so you thought they wanted
to tell you what music you could listen
to and what video games you could play
on the rest of it yeah I mean there
there are horrible evil people they just
wanted to control everything I said and
did was my perception of the Republicans
okay so then Trump comes to New
Hampshire and there we are
there I am so it the day started out
actually at an MSNBC live taping that's
taking place a couple blocks away from
the Trump rally and I kind of went there
first I was very nervous about going
the Trump rally and I went there first
because it was more of a comfort zone
and just started chatting with people
and everyone I told I was like I'm
thinking about going over the rally and
they were like don't do it they're
horrible people they're the lowest of
the low they're going to harass you
one woman actually offered me her pepper
spray to take with me and I was like no
I think I'm gonna be fine it'll be okay
and so then I went over to the rally and
you know you have to get there early
because the line is really big and long
and you're just kind of hanging out and
chatting with people and discovered
there these are not bad people there was
not a Klan uniform in sight I didn't
meet a Nazi that I am aware of there's
normal everyday people like veterans and
schoolteachers and small business owners
that just had different ideas about how
the country should run how shocked were
you I mean it sounds obvious right the
way you're saying it now it's like of
course it's obvious these are regular
people they just happen to have
different political thoughts than what
is sort of more mainstream accepted but
for you as someone that wasn't part of
this bubble you get there and you start
seeing this like were you just like
completely blown away I think I was more
relieved than anything honestly I I
think I was just like oh my god these
are people that I can have a
conversation with because that's
something that is very void in in the
Democratic spaces you have to agree with
everyone and if you don't agree with
them you're a horrible person and so I
had for a long time kept some of my I've
always been a centrist really I'm not
I've never been terribly far left and
I'd always kept my views to myself
whereas like these people I was having
robust conversations with them even in
line and I let it slip a couple times
you know oh I'm I'm a Democrat and they
were like oh my god welcome you were so
glad you're here and that was very
different than what I was expecting
yeah I know the feeling so then you go
and you hear Trump talk and okay there's
some agree to disagree stuff no Nazis
all good you decide to write about it
how'd that work out I did well I almost
didn't even write the article to be
honest cuz I was like I this is not my
lane I don't want to talk about politics
I'm gonna get in trouble I'm gonna make
someone mad whatever but then I sat down
at my desk the next day and I just I had
to get the bolt like out of my system
and so I went on to medium because I was
like I don't really
use medium I hadn't published there in
over a year it's like no one's ever
gonna see this and so I wrote the whole
article that surprised I wrote it in
about 20 minutes and didn't even
proofread it before I posted it and just
threw it up and kinda posted it on a
couple of like Twitter and Facebook and
all that and really thought nothing of
it after that and it got about 200 views
the first day and then the next day it
was like a bomb went off on my life yeah
so what okay so you put it up you're not
really expecting much of anything and
then you know you just can't control the
viral nature of these things do you know
where the energy behind it started was
there a specific person that caught it
that set it on fire I still haven't been
able to figure that out honestly it
started going viral in the morning and
then I know a whole bunch of people from
Fox News tweeted it and glenn beck
tweeted it and at some point in the
afternoon Trump jr. tweeted it and that
was when it all lee started going out of
hand but I mean it just I'm I haven't
been able to pinpoint what exactly
happens okay so the thing goes viral
you're getting support from people that
maybe you traditionally wouldn't have
thought would have supported you the
president son I mean this is this is
getting weird what kind of reaction did
you get and base it why don't you just
lay out a little bit more what you said
in the art of I mean it's sort of what
you've laid out here but maybe a little
more specifically so that when we talk
about the reaction it'll be a little
better friend yeah so basically what I
said in the article was that you know we
need to start taking steps towards one
another and to start healing the
political divides and that I think was
the big message I wanted people to take
away from it is that Trump supporters
are not bad people and you know
hopefully a liberal writing this article
if Trump supporters think that you know
I'm a bad person they're gonna see that
you know someone someone has your back
and I think that that was what a lot of
Trump supporters really appreciated
about it was there was this person
coming and saying you know you're not a
Nazi I know you're not a Nazi we just
have different ideas and let's talk
about those ideas and so yeah and then
it was often running and the response
from the the Trump supporters are the
conservative community and those are not
always the same thing I've discovered
it's it's been amazing
right they they really they they
embraced me and they
with so many of them said you know I
don't agree with you on a lot of
political issues but I'm so glad you
wrote this I'm so glad you're speaking
your mind and let's have those
conversations and a lot of them too I
mean I was overwhelmed with the amount
of notes I got from people saying you
know my husband is a Republican a
Democrat I don't know how to make our
marriage survive war you know people who
have lost family members over this and
so a lot of people really appreciated
that
I think they saw it in me someone that
said you know it's possible to get over
your trump derangement syndrome and that
gave a lot of people hope yeah and then
you know you find yourself on the other
side of this and then suddenly all the
people that you might have thought were
bad guys are being nice to you and
agreeing to disagree and the rest of it
there there's a moment there where you
have to kind of be like oh was I was I
really wrong you have to do a little
self-reflection right yeah and I've been
actually pretty transparent since then
that I you know Trump derangement
syndrome is a real thing I had it for
years I I regret so many of the things
that I said to people over the last
couple years now that I've seen the
other side of it if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell